the International Space Station every
astronaut dreams of working here the
orbiting research laboratory is operated
jointly by the u.s. Russian Japanese
Canadian and European Space Agency's
Claudia Kessler would have loved to fly
there herself she's been passionate
about space ever since she was a girl
back up its mission maybe Devon ish it
always gives me goosebumps to see the
hardware use for space travel I've
satellites space stations rockets and so
forth up close soon Rock Ethan moans
Eliza it was my childhood dream to work
in space flight being an astronaut would
have been my greatest dream but just the
idea of working in space flight always
fascinated no bulb de Foix dogging our
own fought saw button Kessler studied
aerospace engineering but her dream of
becoming an astronaut never got off the
ground as new candidates are only
accepted every 10 to 12 years instead
she launched a recruitment firm
supplying experts to Europe's aerospace
industry half of her recruit ease our
women they're still underrepresented in
the industry stiebel Velma monosyllables
still associate these jobs with men and
checked shirts and cords the classic
nerdy engineer in aerospace we have to
get away from that there are really
exciting things going on and there's a
wide range of professions and
opportunities for women tigra delpha
Frangi woodinville for instance at you
met set the organization analyzes data
from for European weather satellites and
passes it on to weather services in more
than 30 countries over ninety percent of
you met sets employees are male Natalie
cuckoo is one of the exceptions she was
always interested in physics and she
studied in Germany two years ago Claudia
Kessler recruited her to work at you met
set
H will stay is keep I knew there weren't
very many women in the sector but when I
came here I thought that in the last 15
to 20 years more women would have opted
for this kind of profession verdens
issues are sure Bo Finch even german
aerospace firms are always on the
lookout for qualified personnel like OHP
a satellite manufacturer it's also one
of Claudia Kessler's clients mine won't
feel ya my wish is for a female german
astronaut to finally go into space that
would be a great role model for girls
mckean swab her wish could soon come
true recruitment of candidates to be
Germany's first female astronaut to lift
off to the ISS is already underway